All right,
well,
welcome everyone who's physically present and welcome everyone who is virtually
present.
Um,
my job is a really fun one today is to tell you about what many people are
calling the sky event of the decade.
August 21.
There will be a total eclipse visible from one country in one country only and
that's the United States.
They were already calling it the all American eclipse.
I'm sure the administration in Washington is going to try to take full credit
for it.
The minute they wake up to the fact that it's happening.
They're a little busy shuffling the deck chairs on the titanic right now.
But um,
there,
there will eventually I think be a big claim for this and I need,
it is interesting that the clips this total only in the United States,
what's going to happen?
Well,
during an eclipse,
the moon covers the sun and if you think about that,
that's a really remarkable coincidence.
As seen from Earth,
the moon in the sky and the sun in the sky happened to be exactly the same size.
That's not true,
by the way,
from any other planet moon combination in the solar system,
all new from Earth.
Is that true?
Uh,
in case you don't believe me,
here is one of the moons of Mars trying to eclipse the sun as seen from Mars.
And you can see it's pathetic,
right?
There's the little rock called Phobos.
Can't possibly eclipse the sun,
but here from Earth,
the moon and the sun are the same size.
So in eclipse works,
here's what's happening.
During an eclipse geometrically,
uh,
the moon gets in front of the sun and therefore the shadow of the moon makes a
dark spot on the earth.
Now the nice thing is the earth turns.
That's what it does for a living.
That's what it says on his business card,
right?
And the moon moves in its orbit and the relative motion makes the shadow spot of
the eclipse move across the earth.
And that's what's going to happen on August 21st,
you know,
zone about 60 to 70 miles wide.
The eclipse spot,
we'll move across the United States starting on one side of the country in the
Pacific side,
all the way to the Atlantic side.
Um,
just in case you don't believe me,
here is a previous eclipse as seen from space,
and there really is a shadow spot during the eclipse,
right on the earth.
Um,
when this happens,
here's the sequence of events.
Uh,
this is a beautiful sequence of photographs put together by my colleague Rick
Feinberg.
Um,
but you can see the sun slowly begins to see the moon encroaching it,
the moon moves across it.
Uh,
then the eclipses total,
the sky goes dark and night comes in the middle of the day.
It's a really spectacular,
the stars actually come out and around the sun.
This faint but beautiful halo is visible.
That's the sun's atmosphere.
Usually we don't see the suns that seekers,
his sons main bodies so bright.
But when the main body of the sun is actually totally eclipsed,
then the faint atmosphere becomes visible.
Uh,
we'll talk more about that atmosphere a little while,
but then eventually,
and in this case only two and a half minutes later,
but eventually the moon moves away from being directly in front of the sun.
And after,
uh,
the moon moves completely off the sun,
the sun is restored to its former glory.
That's the sequence of events.
Now for those of you who are interested in seeing the total eclipse,
here's the big event before the eclipse,
we comes total here you see a flash of light from the very last valley around
the mountains of the moon,
which is learning sunlight through.
People call this the diamond ring effect cause it looks like there's a,
a ring of light already.
And then one flash in that valley,
which makes for the diamond in the diamond ring.
So this is your clue that the eclipse is about to go total.
Where do we have a total eclipse?
Then?
As I say,
the faint atmosphere of the sun comes out.
This is taken through a telescope.
So here we can actually see prominences great tongues of hot material,
the jet out from the surface of the sun,
some fallback,
some are released into space.
Here's the situation for the dark eclipse spot on earth on August 21 it starts
out in the Pacific,
then moves across the country,
uh,
going diagonally down until it reaches South Carolina where it then goes off the
United States and into the Atlantic Ocean.
Here's a list of states which are going to be seeing the total eclipse.
But remember not all of each of these states is going to see it only a 60 to 70
mile wide path.
By the way,
all these slides are part of a free booklet that I'm going to tell you at toward
the end of the talk,
how you can get off the web.
So if you want to send that map or the little charts that I'm going to show you
to friends,
relatives,
colleagues,
there'll be a way to get all this information out.
You don't need to take notes and I promise this won't be on the quiz.
Um,
but,
uh,
these are the states where it's visible.
And,
um,
the
interesting thing about the eclipse is that no major metropolitan area,
we'll see the total.
I pay any corner of Saint Louis.
We'll have a total eclipse.
Nashville,
Tennessee,
we'll have the total eclipse,
but mostly it's small towns,
rural areas,
national parks,
state parks,
et Cetera.
So this is going to be non urban eclipse for the most part.
I think airbnb is going to clean up on this eclipse because there are many more
private residences and farms.
Then there are major hotels in the can zone.
Here,
for example,
is our nearest state,
which has a total eclipse that's Oregon.
And you'll notice that in Oregon are the eclipse is not going to go over
Portland,
the big city.
It's not going to go over Eugene where the University of Oregon is.
It's going to go through central Oregon and a relatively small talents for the
most part in central Oregon.
Um,
yeah,
the towns that do get the total eclipse are beside themselves with excitement.
For example,
Hopkinsville Kentucky is going to have the longest eclipse just by the geometry
of these Dell have two minutes and 40 seconds of a coach.
So they're already advertising the most exciting two minutes and 40 seconds in
astronomy,
which is a takeoff on the Kentucky Derby,
which is in Kentucky,
which is the most exciting two minutes in sports.
Um,
so
the
calculations by Michael Zeiler cryptographer,
a geographer indicate that about 12 million Americans live within the path of
the total solar eclipse,
which is about 4% of the country.
So if a couple of hundred thousand visitors come into that area and join the
people already living there to enjoy the eclipse,
that should be fine.
And there have been many,
many eclipse.
I Fitzy are not those who have been planning for years to go into this eclipse
zone.
So that's not the problem.
Here's what we are definitely scared about 47 million Americans live within a
hundred mile drive of the eclipse.
And so if in Mobile America right where we are,
so many people have cars,
10 million of these people decide the last weekend.
Hey honey,
let's grab the kids,
put them in the car,
drive a hundred miles and we'll see the eclipse.
Those 10 million additional people will completely overwhelmed the services,
the roads,
et cetera.
In that rural area of the country.
I won't even begin to think of how many people live 200 miles within the
eclipse,
which many of us drive when we have to.
Uh,
so it's going to be a real problem.
And here's the biggest issue in everyone's mind.
And seriously,
if they're an extra million to 10 million people in those areas,
where are they going to go to the bathroom?
Right?
All the porter potties in those states have already been spoken for,
but there are serious concern that they may not be enough facilities.
So what we're telling people is don't leave your eclipse planning for the last
minute.
Those people wise enough,
like all of you listening to this talk,
Dev advanced notice of the eclipse,
please,
planner hand tried to be where the eclipses total.
If you're going to see it the day before,
not that morning,
because that morning we're expected to look like this.
And this is of course misleading because look at all the lanes on this crowded
freeway.
Most of the roads in the subzone or nothing like this,
they're not freeways there.
Small roads,
country roads,
one lane,
two lane places.
So it's going to be a real challenge navigating just before and just after the
eclipse.
Now the rest of the country is going to see a partial eclipse.
If you are off this dark spot,
then the sun will not completely be covered.
The moon will only cover part of the sun.
But in the United States,
pretty much everywhere or substantial bite will be taken out of the sun.
And this eclipse,
the partial eclipse will be visible.
Rethink the almost 500 million people in North America because Canada and Mexico
and even parts of the,
uh,
countries below Mexico,
south of Mexico will be able to see it.
So my 500 million people will be able to see the,
the partial eclipse.
And because when the eclipse is partial,
the sun is still out.
It's dangerous to look at for any length of time.
So we would really need some way to teach all those 500 million people how to
observe the eclipse safely.
And I'm on the National Task Force of the American Astronomical Society,
which has been working for two years to prepare the country for the eclipse.
And this is what we look like at typical meetings,
right?
500 million people.
One are we going to do about all those people?
They're all going to need some way to protect their eyes and the best his
glasses are there are inexpensive paper and plastic glasses,
which are perfect for protecting your eyes.
Those,
uh,
Google employees who are the good sense to actually physically come to the
lecture,
have gotten free glasses.
Uh,
the rest of you there,
I will leave the counter,
do explain how people can get glasses.
What glasses are.
One easy way to do this.
Now let me show you the circumstances of the partial eclipse for the largest
cities in the United States.
They're really quite interesting.
Um,
and again,
if you want to have this chart,
it'll be in the free booklet that I tell you about a little bit later.
But notice in New York City,
uh,
just look at the last column,
71% of the sun's area will be covered.
That's not bad.
Oh,
Los Angeles,
62% of the sun or be covered here in the San Francisco Bay area,
76% of the sun will be covered.
And in Washington DC the cover up will be about 81% and that's pretty typical of
the cover up in Washington DC?
No,
no,
I didn't say that.
Here in the San Francisco Bay area,
here are the circumstances of the clips.
So the partial eclipse for us begins at nine oh one when most people are
arriving at work.
The eclipses that maximum three quarters of the sun covered at 10:15 AM and it's
all over by 11:37 AM.
So if you're planning for that Monday in August,
the crucial times here in the bay area will be from about 10 to ten third.
That's what I would make a special point of being outside with the glasses and
looking at the sun.
A large dark bite will be taken out of the sun,
the sun,
the Sunny d.
If it's a sunny day,
when you're looking big will look like a more cloudy day.
As the moon goes across the,
um,
where the eclipse is total,
uh,
there will be a much more spectacular.
But again,
as I mentioned,
only up small,
uh,
said,
oh,
relatively small towns will get to see the total eclipse.
Ah,
Salem,
Oregon,
Casper,
Wyoming,
St Joseph,
Missouri,
Carbondale,
Illinois.
They are going nuts in Carbondale,
This is the biggest thing that's happening in Carbondale,
Illinois.
Um,
another big factor in terms of your enjoyment of this eclipse,
whether it's total or partial,
is the weather.
If it's completely cloudy or as often happens in San Francisco,
completely foggy,
you will not be able to joy.
Enjoy the eclipse.
So the world's expert on eclipse or weather is Jay Anderson,
this jovial Canadian meteorologist.
He has a whole website updating the weather constantly called [inaudible] dot
com.
But you don't need to go to his website,
all the other websites,
steal the information from him and put it up because he's been keeping track of
decades of weather on August 21 to be able to make a statistical prediction for
the likelihood of cloud cover in any place on August 21.
And here's a quick of his most recent,
our findings on this chart.
You go from left to right across the United States.
So the Pacific coast is on the left,
the Atlantic coast is on the right.
And then up and down the further up you go,
the more likelihood of cloud cover.
So you can see the red line on this chart.
Basically,
there's a great variation from less than 40% in Oregon and parts of Idaho don't,
almost 80% in South Carolina in terms of the likelihood of cloud cover.
So those of you on the West Coast here,
congratulations for picking the better coast for eclipse when,
um,
but this'll be an important factor.
And again,
our fear is that if there are thousands of people in some total eclipse location
who have planned for years to be there for this sky spectacular and in Ghana
location,
the clouds come,
they're not going to be okay with that.
They're going to want to move.
Right.
And these herds of people will try to get out of the cloudy area too where it's
sunny and there'll be incredible gridlock in terms of cars or people trying to
walk or anything like that.
So,
uh,
paying attention in advanced to the weather predictions is also a good idea as
you're making your clips plans.
Now,
as I say,
this will be a Monday in August and from the best weekend pal,
about half the schools in the United States will be in session and half the
schools won't.
So half the kids will be with their parents and half the kids will be with their
teachers.
But for many school districts,
that's the first day of instruction.
That's true.
For example,
in San Francisco and Oakland,
both of them have,
the first day of school will be August 21 so you can just imagine this,
the kids come in and as a WHO's my teacher or here's my teacher,
he's a teacher,
gives that name and that says,
okay,
now there's an eclipse.
What are they going to do?
Are they going to go outside where they be ready,
where they'd be prepared?
I,
and we have no idea.
We'd been working with teachers for two years.
Uh,
we've been doing seminars and webinars and training workshops and putting out
materials.
I'll tell you more about that in a second.
But still,
for the most part,
particularly in elementary schools,
most teachers are not yet aware that the eclipse is happening.
And like many members of the public,
they may have only wake up to this relatively close to the eclipse itself when
the mainstream media begin to make a big deal of this.
So if you know where your children are going to be that day,
try to make preparations for them to be safe and educated.
That is to have information available.
Many people who get information about the eclipse,
one of these talks that I'm giving all over the web,
we're encouraging them to share that with their child's teacher,
to make sure that the teachers are aware of what's happening.
Maybe see if the teacher or the school can order Goss's eclipse glasses for the
whole class,
uh,
help them out if they can't and,
take a look at what's going on.
Um,
now I have an update thing here on my screen.
Uh,
can you help me with that one?
Okay,
great.
All right.
So,
um,
there's a lot of misinformation out there about the eclipse already.
Uh,
for example,
people get mixed up between a lunar and a solar eclipse,
a solar eclipse.
As long as the sun is out,
it's relatively dangerous to look at.
And you need your glasses.
And we've known this for some time.
Uh,
this is a headline from 1918.
That was the last time an eclipse cross the United States.
And it's a thousands for glasses.
It's fun to watch your clips.
Very relevant today except cross out the thousands and write million.
MMM,
I'm sorry.
Is that a similar path?
It's a,
we'd have to calculate.
All right,
so it comes to classes are available from two companies in the United States and
American paper optic and rainbows to beneath.
But of course they're overwhelmed with orders.
Uh,
so the earlier you can order your eclipse glasses,
the better the cub scouts and there will also be available in many other places.
Every Science Museum has the Foothill College Bookstore has them.
I'm sure that a hardware stores will have them.
There's talk of Walmart perhaps having someone who has it
three groceries.
So people have ordered them and it's sort of a chance.
But of course we worried quite a bit about how to distribute glasses to people
who are,
may not be prepared for this,
who will need them.
And,
um,
I actually thought to myself,
where could we distribute glasses to people who don't usually get to share in
events like this?
And that's where we hit on this great idea of public libraries.
Public libraries are in the information distribution business.
And so if we could somehow get glasses to public libraries,
that would be really,
really wonderful.
And so I'm really pleased to say that you guys,
Google,
uh,
joined with a foundation here on the peninsula,
the Gordon and Betty Moore Foundation,
and you,
through your generosity,
we have now distributed 2 million eclipse glasses free of charge to public
libraries around the country.
And I want to applaud all of you at Google for doing this.
Calvin,
thank you so much for being an important part of this.
Uh,
and uh,
here's a now no longer a current map,
but it just gives you an the first 2000 eclipse glasses libraries.
We're now up to 5,000 libraries.
And by the way,
inspired by how popular this program has been and what you guys have done,
NASA has now come in and donated another hundred thousand glasses.
So we hope to be up to 6,000 libraries within the next week.
So people at 6,000 libraries around the country,
we'll be able to get free glasses and,
and we've sent them information booklets and ways to have eclipse events at each
library.
And I've liked,
I was telling Calvin,
I've been speaking at libraries around the bay area and at every library,
it's been standing room only.
There's been just tremendous interest in the eclipse.
We're getting some help from the U s postal service.
The US Postal Service issued an eclipse stamp on June 20th which is the first
ever Therma chromic ink stamp.
And you all know what that means,
right?
No,
I had no,
what the heck is thermo chromatic?
But it's really cool.
It turns out there's an ink.
If you touch it,
the picture changes.
So if you're,
the heat of your finger touches the stamp on the left,
it turns into the stamp on the right.
And this is a real collector's item.
Any post offices already out,
but you can always order the stamps at the u s postal service website,
uspss.gov if you want to get your own souvenir eclipse stamp.
All right.
So as I say,
you guys will have your glasses,
but what about people who don't have to us as,
what are some safe ways of observing the eclipse if you don't happen to have
access to these?
Uh,
paper and plastic glasses.
Well,
there are a number of things you can do.
If you have a tripod with binoculars,
you can cover up one half of the binoculars,
make a sun shade around the other half,
and then project an image through the binoculars onto a white sheet of paper.
The Sun Shade makes for a dark background on which you can see the eclipse.
So if you aren't comfortable and familiar with setting that up,
that's one way to do it.
A much simpler way to safely view the eclipse of you to have glasses is to take
a hand mirror or a woman's compact mirror,
cover it with cardboard leaving only a hole about the size of a die.
And then take that small mirror,
the leftover mirror part and projected an image reflected image onto a wall.
So you try to get the sun into the mirror and then make an image appear on a
wall where a number of people,
I'm looking at it now,
don't try this for the first time on August 21 it takes a little practice to be
able to do it.
So what I would do is to go out on August 20th or August 18 and see where you're
going to be on August 21st bring this covered mirror with you.
Practice until you're good at it.
And that Monday you will be the hero of your neighborhood.
When you get to make a publicly viewable image on a nearby wall.
Um,
if you have nothing else,
you can make a pin hole projector,
just have a piece of cardboard with a pin hole in it and then an image of the
sun on another sheet of paper sub distance away.
But the image is really small and as long as this is the way you want to see the
eclipse,
I have a much better suggestion.
A colander,
colander is full of little pin holes.
Take bring your colanders what you wash the fruit and vegetables in,
right?
Bringing a colander with you on August 21 hold the colander over your shoulder
with the sun at your back and the shadow you make on the pavement.
We'll show lots and lots of pinhole images of the eclipse sun and it is really
spectacular.
People come over and look at you like you're a magician,
and then when you're done,
it's a nice fashion accessory to keep the sun off.
So I suggest everybody bring our calendar to work on August 21.
Um,
but one way or another we want to urge people please to not just protect your
eyes,
but make sure the eyes of everyone you know are safely protected on that day.
Sunglasses are not enough.
Even if they're polarized,
the various things that people have talked about,
smoke glass and so on,
then not good enough to protect your eyes.
The only other thing that works is welder's glass.
If you have a welder friend welder's glass number 14 or greater,
we'll also do it,
but it's gotta be number 14 or greater.
Otherwise,
uh,
either a projected image or eclipse glasses is the way to go.
Now as you've heard,
we've been working with teachers in particular with the National Science
Teachers Association for about two years,
getting information out.
Um,
and they've been really great at it.
We have a book called solar science that we put together for teachers.
Um,
and it's full of activities that teachers can do in the classroom.
But I bring that up because part of that book was an eight page Layman's terms,
nontechnical plain English introduction to the eclipse and the national science
teachers association has very kindly put this entire eight page booklet up on
the web free of charge for anyone.
For those of you here in the room,
it's on your pink sheet that you got,
but for everyone else,
this is how you get to that free nontechnical brochure,
which has all the tables of when and where the eclipse is visible.
You just go to Ennis,
ta.org and SD has national science teachers association and sta.org forward
slash solar science.
And you can download that booklet.
It's free.
You can pat.
It's a pdf file.
Please,
please feel free to send it on to other people.
You know,
if you have people all around the country who are not yet aware of the eclipse,
please share the booklet with them.
It's,
it's a public service.
Um,
one shameless plug.
We have written a book then in shots and I've written a children's book called
when the Sun goes dark,
uh,
which is in the form of a story.
Uh,
two grandparents in the story are eclipse chasers.
They look at eclipses for a hobby and they explained to the grandkids what's
happening with eclipses and as part of the story.
And we suggest a series of activities that families can do with kids to get the
kids ready for the eclipse.
So for example,
you can use a light bulb,
a tennis ball,
and a kid's head to simulate and eclipse.
So there are various family activities in there.
Uh,
some of you who came earlier,
you've got sample copies of the book.
Um,
and please share that with a kid or,
or a school,
uh,
if you're not into children's books.
But,
uh,
this has a quite a bit of good information,
not just about solar eclipses but lunar eclipses as well.
Um,
so I want to just briefly mentioned some citizen science projects connected with
the eclipse.
And uh,
this is the one that you guys are very much involved in.
In Calvin Johnson has taken a great leadership role in this.
Um,
the eclipse mega movie project,
a photographers,
uh,
around the entire total eclipse zone are going to send wirelessly pictures of
the total eclipse with the atmosphere of the sun showing wireless lead to Google
and a team at Google is going to stitch together pictures from all around the
country into what's called a mega movie and a continuous movies showing what the
son was like as the eclipse moved across the United States.
Now the eclipse takes one hour and 37 minutes to go from Oregon to South
Carolina.
That's a lot less time than United,
right?
One hour and 37 minutes to go across the country.
But during that one hour,
37 minutes,
the sun's atmosphere varies quite a bit.
It's,
it's a variable active,
seizing,
energetic kind of region around the sun.
And so we will have an hour and a half record of what the son was doing during
this time.
It's really a very ambitious project that I'm delighted you guys are putting it
together and then it's going to be available publicly when it's done,
which is very nice.
So not just scientists,
but everyone in the country.
We would be able to share in this wonderful movie.
Um,
another,
uh,
citizen science project is called life responds.
It comes from the California Academy of Sciences and Golden Gate Park.
And what they're looking at is animal reactions to the eclipse.
We have a lot of anecdotal evidence about animal reactions,
for example,
because the sky suddenly goes dark.
Many farm animals think it's nighttime and they do the thing they usually do at
nighttime,
which is gold toward the barn or whatever they do.
Um,
eh,
but their stomach and their eyes are not agreeing in terms of the time of day.
So some animals were quite confused about why it's suddenly day.
I said the day has turned into the night.
Um,
we,
as I say,
we have lots of anecdotes about this,
but,
uh,
what the idea here is that people were willing record animal reactions on a
phone app and then send them into the academy.
And instead of just anecdotes,
we will have a database of how animals have reacted all across the eclipse path.
Again,
a very interesting project.
Um,
NASA is all gung ho about the clips.
They have a special NASA website with lots of information.
One of the things they have is what events are happening in each little city
along the eclipse path.
So if you don't just want to go to the clips,
where do you want to go to a music festival or when our food fair or whatever
else is going on.
The NASA side is collecting all the interesting events along the path of the
eclipse.
Uh,
they also have lots of good information and uh,
uh,
maps and so on.
Uh,
the American astronomical society has a website called eclipse.aas.org and if
you're photographing the eclipse,
uh,
not necessarily for the mega movie project,
but just for your own enjoyment.
Uh,
this website is probably the best to go to,
to get information about photography,
both regular still photography and video photography.
There's a whole section with lots of,
lots of good information and links and safety considerations,
et cetera.
So this is a very reliable site in general for clips information.
It clips dot Aas.
Dot.
O r.
G.
Well,
uh,
just a word about why eclipses are such a big deal and we don't get them that
often.
Um,
this is another feature of the solar system that many people are not aware of.
The Moon's orbit is tilted relative to everybody else's orbit.
If you,
for example,
consider the orbit that we make around the sun and then you look at the orbit of
the moon,
it's stilted by about five degrees.
And that tilt means that as the moon goes around us and the moon,
by the way,
goes around those once a moon,
you say month,
but it's really mood,
right?
The moon goes around us once a month and every month there is a time when the
moon and the sun are in the same general part of the sky.
But because of this tilt,
think of it as two Hula hoops because of the hill on a typical month,
the moon is either below the sun or above the sun.
And so there's no eclipse in a typical month.
But as you can see in this diagram,
twice a year,
the Hula hoops cross,
so roughly every six months we have what's called eclipse season when it clips
to become eclipses become possible because the orbit of the of the Moon crosses
the orbit that we make around the sun.
And so the result of that is that somewhere in the world and eclipse as possible
every six months,
it's not always a total eclipse.
Sometimes the moon in its orbit is a little further away and we don't completely
cover the sun.
Sometimes the angle is such a,
we got a partial eclipse.
Sometimes you get a lunar eclipse,
but generally every six months on eclipse as possible.
And then we often get a total eclipse,
but not overpopulated territory,
two thirds of the earth's surface water.
And so it's very likely that a typical clips will fall over just ocean or a
couple of barely inhabited islands and rich people usually retired.
Rich people have time and money will often go to those places and that's their
hobby to chase eclipses,
but very few people actually get to see the eclipse because of the way the
geometry worked out this time.
This is a very democratic eclipse and it falls over a richly populated area
which has access to the web,
right,
and cars and so there's going to be I much greater interest in this eclipse
sizing.
Any other eclipse in history.
This is really the first USA clips of the Internet.
Age of the Google Age,
right information will be available to people all over the web and so we are
very,
very excited and scared about how much public involvement there will be in this
eclipse.
Now,
this is quite a contrast from times past when he clips his were not predictable
like they are now.
These days we can predict eclipses hundreds of years in advance,
but back when they were not predictable.
You can imagine.
Our ancestors got pretty upset when for no reason whatsoever.
In the middle of the day,
the solder whiteout and the legends that we have recorded is that they thought
some monster was eating the sun in Asia.
There were a lot of discussions of a dragon eating the sun,
and they said,
what can we do?
Well,
the idea is to absolutely frightened this monster or this dragon.
Oh,
away from the sun.
That's when the tradition arose of having pots and pans with you.
When you come out to the eclipses,
banging them together,
making a really loud noise to frighten the Dragon,
and you know what you and always work.
That's it.
It always works.
And so the,
the monster went away and the sun came back.
Today we enjoy eclipses for their scientific value.
Here's a little diagram showing the outer layers of the sun.
Uh,
beyond that,
the photos fear the outer edge of the sun.
There are several layers,
complex energetic layers,
including something we call the Chromos fear closer to the sun.
And then the giant outer atmosphere of the sun called the corona.
And you'll notice here on the side that the corona is hotter than the inner
atmosphere and the surface of the sun.
That's fascinating that the outermost atmosphere should be harder than the inner
layers of the sun's surface.
And the answer is magnetism.
There's tremendous magnetic activity in the outer layers and the outer
atmosphere of the sun.
And the result is that it can heat up the particles in the corona and the outer
layers to tremendous temperatures.
Sometimes those particles actually boil off the sun.
There's the,
when a gentle regular wind of partner goes blowing away from the hot outer
layers of the sun.
And then every once in a while we actually get a whole lump of material leaving
the Karuna that's called a coronal mass ejection and it's hot charged particles
leaving the sun moving away from the sun had reasonably great speed.
And luckily most of the time when one of these injections happens,
it's in a random direction in the solar system where there isn't anything.
But every once in a while one of these coronal mass ejections happens to be Jack
did right in the direction of planet earth.
And when that happens,
we have to take precautions.
It can damage sensitive instruments on our spacecraft out in space and it can so
overload the magnetic zone of the earth that the charge particles coming down
actually reached the surface and effect the power grid.
We've had power outages and power surges as a result of these core coronal mass
ejections reaching the earth.
We call this space whether or solar storms and one of the reasons we study this
sun during eclipses in it other times it's to learn more about predicting space
rather were about as good at predicting space rather as we are at earth weather,
which is not very satisfactory.
All right,
now I want it to show you Einstein laughing.
Uh,
and he's laughing here because I'm talking about eclipses and I dunno if you
know,
but it's eclipses are particular tips in particular that made Einstein famous.
Um,
in 1916,
Einstein proposed one of his most outrageous ideas.
One of the strangest theories in all of science called the general theory of
relativity,
which predicts in very oversimplified terms terms that gravity can be thought
of,
not just as a poll,
but as a warping,
a distortion of the very fabric of space and time itself.
And this was such a ridiculous sounding idea that Einstein knew that it wouldn't
be accepted even by his colleagues unless there was some direct proof,
some experimental proof,
that space really did warp with gravity.
I,
it's not calculated that the earth's gravity is so weak cosmically speaking that
the effect was impossible to measure in 1916 from earth on earth,
from the earth's gravity.
But he did calculate that one object in the solar system had enough gravity to
have the warping of space near it be measurable.
And that was the sun.
And I assigned reason that if you could see beams of starlight coming right
close to the sun,
they would travel through slightly warped space.
Those beams of starlight would bend in that warped space.
And so if you look back down,
back to the beam,
to the origin and the beam,
you would see the stars right near the sun in the wrong place in the sky.
They would be slightly out of place because of this warming.
While there's a small tactical problem seeing beams of starlight come by the
sun,
what's that?
Sounds a little bright,
right?
You can't see stars as daytime when the sun is out.
But I,
I was no dummy.
He knew about eclipses.
Said wait until there's any cups during the total eclipse.
The stars actually come out near the sun.
You can see stars in the middle of the day cause the sky right above you is
dark.
He said,
wait til the next total eclipse and take a photograph of the eclipsed sun with
the stars nearby showing.
Look at the position of the stars in the sky.
Compare them to any star atlas where we have the positions of the stars.
You will see that the stars' closest to the Sun will be in the wrong place by a
small amount because of the warping of space.
Uh,
in 1916,
World War One was going on.
Nobody was going on any pleasure trips,
but by 1919,
the world had settled its differences and there was an eclipse visible from an
island off the coast of Africa.
Uh,
an international team of astronomers went to that island,
took a photo of the eclipse.
Here you see some of the,
the newspaper versions of that photo and found that the stars were out of place
near the sun by exactly the amount I had started had predicted.
And this observation of the eclipse is what made Einstein famous.
Before that,
Einstein's work was known to nerds but not to the general public.
When after 1919,
after this eclipse expedition,
Einstein's name became public property,
he would became the best known scientists in the world.
And I love the headline from the New York Times Lights all askew in the heavens.
How could you not read that article?
Lights all askew or skewed means all over the place in the heaven.
Men of science,
right?
More or less a gog,
how can you be more or less a god,
either your mortgage or your loss guy?
Over the result of eclipse ops observations.
Einstein's theory triumphs.
All right,
well,
let me finish up by noting that most of the time when a country has an eclipse,
it has to wait decades.
Maybe centuries before another eclipse comes its way.
But here in the United States,
we are very lucky.
It turns out if you miss this eclipse,
there will be another eclipse in only seven years,
seven years.
Um,
put the,
the,
the date,
put this on your social calendar is April 8th,
2024 there will be another eclipse crossing the country.
You can see,
uh,
on this diagram that across crosses in an x shape relative to this eclipse.
This eclipse is being shown from Oregon to South Carolina here.
It's going to come Mexico to Canada,
but it's going to cross the United States as well.
And so we will have another opportunity to use the glasses.
You got to explain things to the kids and enjoy an eclipse,
uh,
on,
in only seven years
old.
It turns out the place where it crosses his Carbondale,
Illinois.
That's why they're so excited.
All right.
That's all right.
So,
um,
the out,
this is the sky during the eclipse this time in August 21.
I'm not going to go through this,
but I will point out the,
just to the right of the eclipse sun is Venus.
So there will be one bright spot that everyone can recognize as an eclipse
happens just to the right of the sun is the planet Venus.
Well,
I hope I've given you a lot to chew on,
uh,
during this,
during this discussion.
But I do want to say that,
uh,
one of the great things about the Internet is that there's all this information
available.
One of the things that worries all of us about the Internet is that there's a
lot of misinformation available and there's already a lot of discussion on the
Internet that this eclipse is the end of the world.
The terrible things are going to happen at some sort of prophecy,
et cetera.
So let's try to,
to not worry about those things.
This is a perfectly natural phenomenon.
The world will continue for good or for bad after the eclipse,
if you like us are a little overwhelmed by the eclipse experience.
There's always a little bit of this to take care of the problem,
but more seriously,
I want to wish all of you cause you're a skies and good companions on August
21st thank you very much.
Should I answer questions?
What?
I don't know how things work from the all time.
Great.
Yes,
yes.
Well these also be useful for watching the occasional sunrise and sunset.
Yes.
So the,
the good thing about these glasses is that you can use them to watch the sun
anytime.
So here are the glasses,
right?
These are the Google ones,
I,
yes,
like lifts mega movie,
Google.
So you can use these gases to watch the sun ain't got,
the main thing to watch out for is that that especially if you're working with
kids,
that they don't crinkle or put any holes into the material that's in front of
your eyes.
As long as that material is intact,
it's long lasting.
You can use it.
You can look at the sun for a long period of time and not hurt yourself.
And yes,
when the sun is again active right now we're what we call solar minimum.
The Sun's activity is at its lowest level in the 11 year cycle of solar
activity,
but in five or six years when we to reach solar maximum,
when there are lots of sunspots groups on the sun,
this is perfectly okay for watching the sun,
uh,
and seeing sunspots or just watching during the sunrise or sunset.
Absolutely.
So couple of quick questions.
Uh,
what would you recommend for people wear glasses can be used,
this kind of thing.
And the other question is,
do,
can you watch the total,
I mean the entirety of the eclipse with these losses or do you recommend just
watching it for a few seconds and watching again?
Great.
So this is really important.
First of all,
if you're wear glasses,
just put these in front of your glasses.
That's what I do is I keep my,
God says I'm cause otherwise everything is fuzzy in the world.
Right?
And so I just put these in front of my glasses and there's no problem.
But so let's you're really clear about when you need the glasses do when you
don't,
any time the sun is out,
you need the glasses.
Anytime there's a total eclipse,
put the glasses away.
You don't need them.
So for those people going to the eclipse path for the two minutes of the
eclipse,
don't use the glasses.
You'll miss all the beautiful thing phenomena in the Scott.
You only need the glasses when the sun is out.
Um,
now one more.
Where as long as you've given me this opportunity,
let me say one more word about observing the eclipse.
If you're going to go and see the total eclipse,
I've already said,
plan ahead.
Make sure when you're there in the crowded zone,
you have gas for your car,
you have some food and drink with you,
et cetera.
But also don't try to take a photograph if this is your first eclipse.
The phenomenon itself is overwhelmingly beautiful.
It's eerie,
it's all other world.
If you've never seen an eclipse,
it's amazing.
You suddenly see the sun go out,
the stars come out,
you see this halo around the sun.
People are just going,
oh my God,
you can,
I mean,
it's really an amazing thing and there's only two minutes this time.
It's a relatively shorter cubs.
Don't fiddle with equipment.
Don't try to take pictures.
Lots of people with lots of experience with Dick taking.
No offense.
Much better pictures than you.
Right.
I knew all be in the movie anyway,
so just enjoy it.
Take the glasses off during the total part and just enjoy it.
If you can't go to this total eclipse because you haven't planned,
then now you have seven years to plan for the next one and see if you can take
time off to be in the 2024 eclipse.
Thank you for asking.
Other questions,
thoughts?
Uh,
I was just thinking that when I was a kid,
I used to,
uh,
a solar eclipse.
It wasn't total.
He was in Europe and uh,
in the Times that we didn't have digital cameras,
it was easy to make those glasses because I just used the film.
But without being imprinted.
The film that we had and it was completely dark except for where the song was.
Yeah,
that's right.
In the old days,
we used to use many layers,
not just one.
I hope that many layers of portal exposed.
Phil,
does anyone still remember Phil?
Right in the euro digital photography,
chemical photography has got the way of the dinosaur,
but yes,
many layers of film were thought to be.
Okay,
not so great.
It turns out this,
this kind of plastic with Daryl is much better.
It wasn't exposed at all,
so it was the one that is not exposed to is completely dark,
completely.
Dot.
Yeah.
Never,
nevertheless,
I recommend these over.
Yup.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Can you explain what's so special about those glasses?
Was a bake off and how do they work?
Yeah.
Oh sure.
So the glasses are just made of a,
a mylar like plastic.
What it does is it's so dark,
it's so good at cutting light out that it cuts out both the visible light and
the ultraviolet light of the sun.
And so normally right,
it hurts to look at this on your eye is equipped to react to staring at the sun.
And nobody stares at the sun in their right mind.
But during an eclipse,
astronomical enthusiasm can overwhelm common sense and people tend to look
longer than they should.
With these glasses,
all the rays that can hurt your eyes are cut out and you'll see if you're trying
to put them on regularly,
you can't see anything in any normal environment.
You need the sun to be bright enough to get through these lenses.
So these are very good at cutting out the vast majority of the visible light and
the ultraviolet light.
And as I say,
if you can't get glasses here,
um,
many other places will have glasses.
There's a organization,
San Francisco called the astronomical society.
The Pacific,
they have glasses for sale to foothill college bookstore has them.
Um,
I'm sure that the tech museum and other places around here,
we'll have them.
So check it out if you can't get them from middle.
And one note on that as well.
If you're a Googler,
we are sending them to a lot of remote offices.
So if you're calling,
if you're watching the live stream,
uh,
we should have some at the lobby at the remote office and we're handing them out
in building 1225 here in mountain view,
which is where they're making sense and it
seems based,
right?
So maybe I should say that Google hasn't just restricted it's generous donation
to the library's.
There have been many other educational projects which have received Google
glasses.
I,
I know that for example,
the American Astronomical Society has a project to get glasses to underserved
minority schools to Indian reservations,
et cetera.
And you've generously contributed glasses to that project and to many other
educational settings.
So again,
thanks all of you for being part of the eclipse outreach for this eclipse
where I will thank you very much for coming and I hope this is enlightened you a
little bit and light.